I was thinking there needs to be a
Racing League where uh after they drive
they can get out and just [__] fight
each other yes the end of the race you
park in the grid position run to the
Finish Line no then you run into a
massive ring like 20 man free for all
maybe you get like bonuses that you get
weapons if you come in first that's the
true winner yeah you can do 80 laps in
Toronto and then you can hop out the car
and fight 19 guys that's sick you should
start that race boxing no no no
no no it's somewhere with that I take
that back that's not a good name for
that race no you heard it here first
folks Cody Co wants to start racing race
Wars yeah how about that